okay so these films are talking about
the weaknesses in
all of the suburbs and then after I've
covered the the weak observations
that I've known best in people
and they're more coverage to bury and
look at the weakness within what might
be the endless very problems the moment
the holding of the can the timing all
these points uh they're in the hole
seven
to those kids first and when you go to
Department of practice and that's when
it will really start to notice unless
you've observed them really controlled
all these uh errors and
mannerisms
okay
the next point so fingers space
he'd tell me posture
I love all because you're on your own
the next thing I see is um
cover
it's bigger elbows and become very wide
now they're wider than my body
and then they come down
wind up on body come down
so I try to teach people if this happens
to be in front of a boys trying to get
in front of mirrors or a large patio
window or something if you can and
observe yourself always observe yourself
some help film yourself
occasionally you know put your phone on
film and film yourself okay so these
since we used to say well they go
through a door
if you walk through a door straight
your shoulders go through so much to
your
elbows
so what's your elbows
so the thing that I notice people forget
is when they're going up they've got to
keep their elbows this feeling like this
like you know the old word bellows
bring them in here you're gonna keep
them in and come down
in the end hopefully
don't just stay
where they should be
sometimes the hands will collapse so I'm
going to show you from the side yeah
yeah sometimes
trying to keep the head the elbows in
means that the hands come really close
to the head here
even touching the head or you might even
hit your head with the with the cane a
lot of people hit the head with the can
because it comes too close
okay so the next point is elbows in but
this feeling is high this is high
hey so it's stretching up
elbows in breathing out breathing in
elbows in just pushing out
breathing out so just show you the
action
so of course I'm exaggerating it so
first of all I show you the exaggerated
one
actually
more advanced people tend to let this
hand a little bit more
loose
but for beginners
keep them closed
all the time
and by pushing it up
it helps
if you open the armpit stretch the body
again and full account okay so get a
fuller cut
[Music]
hands Gap
trigger fingers
climbing
cut
the foot
elbows in
elbows starting
elbows
staying
okay
there's a lot in that one
so I'm going to break it down put it on
really slow if you look at this on
YouTube you can go down to 0.2 for Life
watch it all in slow motion try and get
to that point of slow motion
said
okay thank you for your time